we're facing a situation where this
world-renowned human rights organization
amnesty international is in the
headlines
for all the wrong reasons following
revelations
uh about a quote toxic work
culture in this organization that was
discovered by an
independent review carried out by the
conterra group consultancy that found
that things like
bullying public humiliation nepotism
discrimination
overwork are widespread
at amnesty international this was
discovered following
interviews and discussions with
as many as 70 percent of staff
and the situation has been described as
quote
a state of emergency it has to do with
the atmosphere and working culture in
the organization
that is very isolating i've never before
worked in a place
where everyone works so alone it's
because of a system where everyone is
scared stressed and overworked
and thus can only focus on their own
survival
there was a real culture of bullying
right up until i left several years ago
particularly of middle managers well
this review
found also what it described to be as a
martyrdom culture because of this
reputation and status that amnesty
international has
throughout the world and according to
this review the credibility of this
organization could now come under
question
any organization that touts protecting
human rights as its mission
but is itself mired in a conflictual and
adversarial culture
will lose credibility as organizational
rifts and evidence of nepotism and
hypocrisy become
public knowledge they will be used by
the government and other opponents of
amnesty's work
to undercut or dismiss amnesty's
advocacy around the world
fundamentally jeopardizing the
organization's mission
in terms of some numbers that were
provided it was said that as
many as over 50 percent of employees
feel like they're not
valued and as many as 39 have developed
health and or mental issues as a result
of the work
that they do and in terms of the
reaction we've seen from
amnesty we know that they have found
these conclusions troubling and have
said that they will
try to carry out some kind of reforms
and all of this of course gets revealed
uh following
two suicides uh of employees of amnesty
international that took place
back in 2018 within six weeks of each
other
that prompted a series of reviews
including this latest one
you